Do We Have Different Types of Sets to Understand Try to Write
Down the Set of Integers
Using the Listing Method We Open
the Parentheses Right Three Dots End -4 -3 -2
-1 This List Covers All the Negative
Integers But We Have Been  Needed to cover all the
integers so we write a 02 and now we just have to cover all the
positive integers 1 to three
four and three dots again here the three
dots mean that the numbers continue to
infinity on both sides these types of
sets  Var the elements are infinite are called infinite
sets and now we have been asked to represent
a set to cover all the colors of the
rainbow we open the brackets and right violet indigo
blue green yellow orange and red and
close the brackets this type of sets in which
The elements are finite are called finite
sets Let me give you the final two
examples Find out if the sets are finite and infinite The
first example is the set of
names of months in the year and the second
example is a set of whole numbers  Try Finding If They Are
Fight Or
Infinite This
Set Would Be Fine It A There Are 12
Months In A Year But This Set Is Infinite Because Whole Numb
Start From Zero And Never
[Music]
End